sobre la isla japonesa de okido una bola
de fuego atravesó el cielo difundidas
por la televisión japonesa estas
imágenes serían las de un misil
disparado el sábado por Correa del Norte
antes Corea del Sur dio la alerta el
anuncio fue seguido por viajeros en la
estación de tren de seúl El misil
recorrió 900 kilómetros antes de
estrellarse en la zona económica
exclusiva de Japón según Tokio
estos disparos son una provocación a la
comunidad internacional en su conjunto y
naturalmente hemos protestado
enérgicamente
entonces
la seguridad del pueblo japonés es lo
más importante antes que cualquier otra
cosa
las autoridades japonesas afirman que se
trataba de un misil balístico
intercontinental según los expertos
Piñón podría haber querido probar un
misil de combustible sólido una
tecnología que el régimen norcoreano
Busca dominar es más fácil de almacenar
y más difícil de detectar desde
noviembre de 2022 este es el segundo
misil norcoreano que cae en la zona
económica exclusiva japonesa en los
últimos meses la tensión ha aumentado en
la región al intensificarse los
lanzamientos de prueba de Corea del
Norte y como represalia los ejercicios
militares conjuntos entre seúl y Estados
Unidos de hecho los disparos de prueba
del sábado se producen pocos días antes
del inicio de ejercicios simulados entre
los dos aliados para prepararse ante un
posible ataque nuclear de Unión en otro
signo de escalada las autoridades
surcoreanas calificaron el jueves a su
vecino de enemigo un término que no
utilizaban Desde hacía seis años